wir freuen uns gedacht wir sind heute in
haltern am see und ich probiere an einem
tag pflichten zu lernen und so könnte
das auslaugen
[Musik]
ja
dass sich das auto mit dem wir das
probieren werden e46 328 größeren fünf
sind mit gesperrten differenzial so ein
sportlenkrad ist da drin ich bin super
hype und auch ein bisschen aufgeregt ich
bekomme jetzt erstmal ein bisschen
theorie erklärt damit ich nicht komplett
rheins hacke und wir das irgendwie in
diesen zwei stunden hinbekommen die
theoretischen basics habe ich dann
innerhalb von 15 minuten erklärt
bekommen wie startet man in den refrain
wie verhält sich das auto und was tue
ich wenn ich mal die kontrolle verlieren
sollte natürlich lernt man das ganze
habe erst so richtig im auto weswegen
wir direkt auf die schleuder platte
gegangen
[Musik]
okay das ist meine meine einzige
information
das ist eine einzige information
im prinzip funktioniert das ganze so
dass man auf die schleuder platte drauf
fällt einem dann eine zufällige richtung
das heck ausgebrochen wird aus der
drohnen perspektive kann man ziemlich
genau erkennen wie das ganze
funktioniert
ich habe wirklich das gefühl dass das so
ein bisschen intuition dass ich feiere
jetzt schon seit mehr als fünf jahren
auto bin viele kilometer gefahren war
fiel auf dem motorrad unterwegs ich habe
irgendwie einfach als nicht das ist so
ein bisschen drin
die hacker es macht echt richtig bock du
hast gegengelenkt er ist genau schluss
super ehrlich geil
das erste was mir gerade in den sinn
gekommen ist war ich verkaufe den test
land kaufen in e46 es macht so lockt das
haben wir einige male gemacht bis wir
die platte zur maximalen intensität
gesteigert hatten und auch mit der
maximalen geschwindigkeit von 50 km h
drauf gefahren sind und es jedes mal
geklappt hat hier ist also wir können
weitermachen mit der zweiten übung die
endlich richtung dürften geht
[Musik]
wir steigen direkt anlegen der rektor
lenkimpuls links gasstoß kommt zur
forderungen ganz schön gegen denken und
jetzt so ein bisschen wichtig ist glaube
ich vom gas weg also jetzt merkt es
jetzt kommt er versprüht das ganze auf
einer runde nutzfläche gemacht die
ungefähr so eine vereiste schneedecke
limitiert da können wir das alles in
relativ langsamer geschwindigkeit machen
um uns einfach so langsam rantasten auch
von außen sieht das relativ wenig
spektakulär so ein bisschen wie slow mo
aus aber super um ein bisschen übung zu
bekommen
[Musik]
man kann hoffen gemerkt vom gas runter
gehen so dass wir da ich fast nie drauf
und damit zu diesem buch
geil dass man das macht am anfang war
das ein super ungewohntes gefühl und ich
habe erst ein paar probleme das ist dann
aber auch relativ schnell wieder
verflogen und irgendwann hat perfekt
geklappt
wir haben von der ersten bis zur letzten
übungen das ganze nicht nur in die eine
richtung probiert sondern auch in die
andere also linkskurven und rechtskurven
man hat ja immer so eine
schokoladenseite bei mir ist die
linkskurve aber im endeffekt muss man es
in beide richtungen können um zum einen
die durch zu connecten und zum anderen
um in jede richtung flüchten zu können
das hält nie die möglichkeit so etwas
auszukennen im normalen leben habe ich
auch das auto nicht dazu strecke nicht
dazu und hier habe ich beides
möglichkeiten von da sind wir dann aber
in die richtigen trifft auf dem asphalt
gewechselt und das war noch mal was
komplett anderes team jetzt nur mit als
beispiel dass man sie es im trockenen
welche trifft überhaupt im trockenen 4
jetzt bin ich auch nur so viel
sie ist an der lenkung wir sind mehr
bezahlen
ja genau
nicht viel wenn ich jetzt merke ich will
dass du ein bisschen weiter raus kommt
und sagt ich einmal
jetzt könnte ich jetzt gebe ich vollgas
jetzt kommt der um dann gehe ich weg und
darum gehe ich mit das auto hat komplett
anders reagiert das habe ich sogar schon
auf dem beifahrersitz bemerkt als wenn
das ganze erklärt wurde
man muss mit deutlich mehr gas fahren
das auto ist viel reaktionsfreudige und
einfach ein bisschen schwieriger zu
kontrollieren und genau deswegen hat es
auch einige versuche gebraucht bis das
ansatzweise geklappt hat
[Musik]
die hosen gemacht
lassen sie sich 90 prozent noch die mit
dem gab buchmesse mit dem jetpack eine
kleine ecke verlage und dann viel zu
lesen
irgendwann hat es dann aber klick
gemacht und auf einmal war ich die ganze
zeit in einem vernünftigen winkel in
einem vernünftigen griff konnte ihn
halten und hat auch eigentlich hier bis
heute schafft
[Musik]
der markt habe nun merkte da kommt
ansatzweise zurückfordern wenn hinterher
ich sag mal so 15 20 minuten machen an
hasselt auf jeden fall raus was du auf
feinsten
auf dem papier
[Musik]
ja
das schlägt ja geil
die andere sagte huber
[Musik]
wie viel man aus diesem wagen heraus
bekommt oder dass man so viel aus diesem
wagen heraus bekommt hätte ich wirklich
nicht gedacht dass es so gut klappt
innerhalb von einer halben oder
dreiviertel stunde hätte ich auch nicht
gedacht das macht wirklich unglaublich
spaß jetzt mal kurz fünf minuten pause
und dann geht es weiter
aber es ist echt unglaublich tokyo drift
style
jetzt ist es so weit nicht nur die gopro
in den autos sondern mag fährt mit ich
weiß nicht ob das eine gute idee es hat
eine große kamera in der hand und jetzt
probieren wir das ganze noch mal also
hier über diesen knopf hier unten am
armaturenbrett können wir alle systeme
ausschalten
die uns daran hindern wollen würden zu
driften erst ergangen wir fahren mit
circa 20 km h über die weiße enge linie
reihe neben dem auto einen impuls
drücken aufs gas und dann sollte der
schon rum kommen
tokio nicht wirklich das ist so was los
oder gar nicht so sicher weiter hey das
ist so geil
so was ist so dass das spiel 705 sich
zutrauen vernünftig gas zu geben und dem
wirklich einen impuls zu geben um
wirklich zu starten also am anfang habe
ich das ein bisschen zu sanft gemacht
und musste dann mit viel gas und vielen
lenkung korrigieren es geht aber
eigentlich darum einmal mit dem fetten
stoß reinzugehen und dann nur noch
minimal zu verlieren also das ist der
traum fall
46 das war ein sehr sehr nice sehr
besonderes gefühl man hat halt ansonsten
außerhalb von seinem durch training
nicht so viele möglichkeiten das ganze
auszuprobieren ich habe nicht das
richtige auto und auch einfach nicht den
richtigen platz dazu wenn das bei euch
genauso ist jack dem link in der video
beschreibung tech track day 24 aus die
sind in haltern haben das ganze für mich
möglich gemacht ist ein super meist
geschenk mit dem kot dave bekommt ihr
dort zehn prozent und könnte das ganze
mal ausprobieren ist nichts bezahlt ist
das war einfach super korrekt von denen
dass sie es mit mir gemacht haben und
ich kann es einfach nur jedem empfehlen
der das ganze mal ausprobieren will und
wirklich professionell lernen will weil
man das so im straßenverkehr und so
natürlich nicht machen kann sehr sehr
nice vielen dank an die jungs von track
day 24 jack den link in der video
beschreibung aus wir machen weiter und
konnte dann anfangen mich so ein
bisschen auszuprobieren habe zb auf der
stelle im kreis gedriftet und pylonen
drumherum
[Musik]
die
wag
[Musik]
das hat alles super funktioniert weil es
sehr nah an den übungen davor war das
große finale war aber was komplett
anderes hat ja auch nicht so viel power
und wenn er dann nicht sofort umgesetzt
wird herauskommt dann aber kurz rein
okay also von großes finale
die königsdisziplin der große kreisel
den ich nicht mehr im ersten gang fahren
muss sondern im zweiten
wir sind kurz davor ich werde einfach
ins kalte wasser geschmissen und soll
das jetzt hier machen
ich bin sehr gespannt wir haben weniger
neigungswinkel
jetzt gilt es hierbei ging es darum im
großen kreis mit viel tempo im zweiten
gang riesige bild zu machen
quasi die realitätsnahe bedingungen
jetzt gilt es betrifft
aber ich merke auf jeden fall dass man
das deutlich mehr probleme macht als als
im kleiner was wir tun
meine konzentration ist immer schlechter
geworden das licht ist schlechter
geworden und wir hatten auch nicht mehr
so viel zeit weil wir schon zwei stunden
dran waren und eigentlich schon über der
zeit
ich hab mich dann ins auto gesetzt
komplett fokussiert und dann hat es
geschafft
[Musik]
ob das hat unfassbar viel spaß gemacht
ich hoffe euch hat das video auch
gefallen wenn ja lasst mir gerne michael
vergesst nicht den kanal zu abonnieren
ich habe die letzten tage schon nach
bmws mikucki umbauen könnte um dann so
ein dreck tool zu haben bringt
wahrscheinlich nichts ändern kann ich es
nicht machen
bin aber wirklich so halb das hat so
spaß gemacht dass ich mit dem gedanken
die ganze zeit beim lüften bin vielen
dank an die jungs von check24 wenn ihr
das ganze mal ausprobieren wollt dann
checkt die jungs aus sehen uns nächste
woche wieder vergesse nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren
macht's gut
naja wie vor dem anpfiff waren